(upbeat music)
- Hello. Good morning
- Hello
- From Munich.
- In Germany.
- In Germany. We just flew here from L.A.
and we're going to be
attending Oktoberfest,
which is the biggest beer
festival in the whole world.
We're gonna go try the food
and drinks there and probably
mostly beer and we'll show
you how it looks like.
We're both wearing the
traditional outfits.
- Yours is called dirndl.
- Dirndl.
- And mine is called lederhose.
- Lederhose.
(cheerful music)
- Okay, so just entered
Oktoberfest. Everyone's dressed up.
Apparently you buy this
to your girlfriend.
- [Man] For the girl.
- For the girl.
I'm a princess. We have a local here.
- So this is the oldest
brewery in Bavaria.
- That's gonna go in there, right?
- Yeah, let's go in there.
(cheerful music)
- Prost.
- So we're gonna order some food.
Try what's over here and
we're gonna eat some food
outside as well but probably
later when we're drunker.
- Ente. It's like a mashed
potato formed in the broth.
- Potato's very chewy. I like
the texture. This is pork?
- [Man] Schweinshaxn.
Rotkraut. Sauerkraut.
- Interesting.
- [Man] And this is weifswurst.
It's like white sausage
that's famous in Bavaria.
- [Woman] It looks kind of
weird. You have to open it.
- [Man] Yeah.
- It's similar to normal sausage but...
- It's plain.
- Not as salty and soft, like really soft.
(upbeat music)
- [Announcer] Oans! Zwoa! Drei!
- G'suffa!
(upbeat music)
- [Woman] Got a half meter bratwurst.
It's so juicy and so full of flavor.
I like this more than a hot dog.
(upbeat music)
- I got some currywurst with fries.
- I got a leberkässemmel.
- The curry ketchup goes
so well with the sausage.
This is literally my favorite.
Can't forget the pretzels.
They have big and small ones here.
Got a second currywurst.
Cause it's so good.
This time I got it with some bread.
German toilets are a little different.
It's quite small.
It's getting pretty cold so we're
gonna hang out in the tent.
There are around like 10 to 15 tents here.
It's kind of like bar hopping, you just go
to different tents and drink and eat.
- [Man] Every tent is a big party.
- Big pickle.
Very juicy.
(chanting)
(cheerful music)
- I can say that I'm pretty drunk.
And we're gonna go eat more food.
(upbeat music)